sie träumen von Freiheit Frieden
Selbstbestimmung 44 Jahre nach der
Islamischen Revolution wollen sich die
Frauen im Iran nicht mehr beherrschen
lassen sie kämpfen gegen das harte
Regime ihres Landes wir wollen unsere
Rechte Menschenrechte wieder zurück
haben
woher kommt der Mut iranischer Frauen
und kann ihre Revolte gelingen Auftakt
für unser dokthema Frau Leben Freiheit
morgen
22:15 Uhr bei Phoenix
die Zukunft der Ukraine liegt in der
NATO und das wurde zum Schluss des
Gipfels in Vilnius betont nur wann fängt
diese Zukunft an die Erwartungen waren
hoch an den Gipfel in Litauen der
ukrainische Präsident gestern erst
fordern fast wütend um sich dann heute
harmonisch neben Generalsekretär
Stolberg zu präsentieren der Westen wird
noch mehr Waffen liefern ein NATO
Ukraine Rat soll eingesetzt werden es
war ein schwieriges Ringen Deutschland
und die USA er zurückhaltend zwischen
abschreckungen und der Angst womöglicher
Eskalation durch Russland NATO im
Ukraine Dilemma Bündnis im Stress-Test
unser Thema in der phönix-runde
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
wir verstehen dass einige NATO-Staaten
Angst haben jetzt über eine Aufnahme zu
sprechen
denn keiner möchte einen Weltkrieg
die Unterstützung wird weit in die
Zukunft reichen wir werden der Ukraine
helfen eine starke fähige Verteidigung
zu Lande zu Luft und zu Wasser
aufzubauen
die Präsidenten beiden und selensky
heute zum Abschluss des Nato-Gipfels
herzlich willkommen zur Phönix Runde ich
darf in meine Gäste vorstellen Stefanie
Babs ist bei uns ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin hat über 20
Jahre in der NATO gearbeitet zuletzt als
stellvertretende Beigeordnete
Generalsekretärin ich begrüße Herbert
Prantl Autor und Kolumnist der
Süddeutschen Zeitung Markus Matthias
Keup ist bei uns militärökonom er lehrt
seit 2013 an der ETH Zürich der
ausbildungsstätter für Berufsoffiziere
der Schweizer Armee ich begrüßte Tobias
Feller wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am
Institut für Friedensforschung und
Sicherheitspolitik an der Universität
Hamburg
Frau Papst wir haben heute einen anderen
silensky erlebt als den den wir gestern
gesehen haben sie haben heute in einem
Interview den Gipfel als strategische
Nullnummer bezeichnet warum
lassen sie ja mich vielleicht mit zwei
Sätzen noch mal kurz den Kontext
darstellen um was ging es bei diesem
Gipfel
hier ist ein aggressives
revisionistisches Russland das seit gut
zwei Jahrzehnten durch Europa läuft
Grenzen versucht mit Gewalt zu
verschieben und nun seit 16 Monaten ein
ethnischen Vernichtungskrieg in der
Mitte Europas angeht das ist die eine
Seite und die andere Seite das ist der
die NATO die vor mittlerweile 75 Jahren
gegründet worden ist um europäische
Sicherheit zu gewährleisten und wenn ich
mich jetzt mal ein bisschen löse von all
diesen ganzen rhetorischen und
wortakrobatischen messages also den
Botschaften das Gefühl dann bleibt
unterm Strich die Botschaft übrig hier
ist eine NATO die nicht bereit ist über
die Rolle des Unterstützers
hinauszugehen und letztendlich der
Ukraine den militärischen Kampf gegen
dieses expansionistische terroristische
Regime in Russland weiter überlässt
haben wir eben gehört gesagt er versteht
die besorgt so die Sorgen der NATO
Ländern wolle ja schließlich kein
Weltkrieg verbrannte wir haben sie das
empfunden die Unterstützung der NATO für
die Ukraine jetzt also ich bin froh dass
es nicht so ist wie sich Frau Papst
wünscht ich will nicht dass ich die NATO
als NATO an diesem Krieg beteiligt ich
will keine Eskalation haben ich will
nicht dass wir einen dritten Weltkriegen
näher rücken und ich bin auch nicht der
Meinung dass das eine strategische
Nullnummer war die Nato hat bei diesem
Gipfel in Vilnius weiterentwickelt was
sie vor einem Jahr
beim Gipfel in Madrid begonnen hat es
hat neues strategische Konzepte
entwickelt sie zeigt eine Einigkeit und
diese Einigkeit die die Natur zeigt ist
ja durchaus dem ergressor zu verdanken
in Anführungszeichen die NATO ist wieder
stark geworden es ist einigermaßen einig
geworden auch wenn es viel
seltsames und ungutes und unschönes
Getränke gab im Vorfeld ich glaube das
Abschlusspapier ist doch so dass man es
mit Wohlwollen betrachten kann die NATO
zeigt sich als stärker als wir es vor
Jahren geglaubt haben und das ist keine
Entwicklung die verurteilen kann was ich
wirklich nicht will und das doch mal
ganz deutlich zu sagen auf Rabatt ich
will nicht dass die Eskalation noch
weitergeht ich will nicht dass wir uns
wir die Bundesrepublik wir die NATO wir
die anderen naturstaaten sich im Krieg
mit Russland befinden
für furchtbar für
alle alles was Politik hergibt muss
versuchen dies zu verhindern
wie sehen Sie es wie stark ist die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine von Seiten
der NATO und wie stark sollte sie ihrer
Meinung nach sein ich denke man sollte
sich mal von dem Wort Eskalation lösen
weil die einzige Nation die diesen Krieg
eskaliert ist Russland der Krieg könnte
morgen vorbei sein sage ich immer wieder
wenn Russland seine völkerrechtlich
eingefallene Truppen abziehen würde aber
davon abgesehen ich denke der Gipfel hat
das Maximum dessen gebracht dass man
realistischerweise erwarten konnte es
ist klar dass man eine Ukraine die in
einem territorialen Konflikt steht in
einem Abwehr Kampf gegen dieses völlig
richtig imperiale Regime dass man sie
nicht aufnehmen kann solange dieser
Krieg andauert das ist klar
ich bin nicht glücklich mit Stichworten
wie Eskalation dritter Weltkrieg und so
weiter weil da so solche emotionalen
Debatten losgehen die mit der
militärischen Realität ja natürlich aber
das hat mit dem militärischen Realität
wenig zu tun und die sieht so aus man
wird die Ukraine aufrüsten also sie wird
sowohl selber aufrüsten als auch von den
westlichen Partnern wird sie aufgerüstet
werden es wird gar nicht anders gehen
weil doch eben was glauben Sie was wir
für ein Russland bekommen nach dem Krieg
also es ist sicher kein friedliebendes
Russland dass ich wieder wunderbar
einfügt in irgendeine europäische
Völkerfamilie des Russland unter diesem
Regime ist nicht mehr Europa das muss
man als klar sagen und die Ukraine steht
an vorderster ab wer Front gegen dieses
Regime und ähm die die Folge ist klar
also wir wir kommen in ein neues
Zeitalter hinein wo wir jetzt vielleicht
nicht die historische blockcha
Konfrontation erleben aber ein neues
Zeitalter der Aufrüstung und ich denke
damit das ist der eigentliche Schritt
also bevor wir jetzt hier über
bündnisfragen diskutieren
wir noch intensiv
wenn man
dieses und Eskalation nicht aber es gibt
viele Menschen die befürchten und gerade
eine Eskalation sehen Sie jetzt nach
diesem NATO-Gipfel dass die Gefahr der
Eskalation oder der einer unangemessen
oder stärkeren Reaktion durch Russland
eher vom Tisch ist oder ist die jetzt
höher stärker geworden ich würde sagen
dass der Gipfel die gipfelergebnisse
sind im Endeffekt eine Fortschreibung
des Status quo wo eben versucht wird ja
eine direkte Konfiguration
militärische Ebene zwischen Russland
oder NATO zu vermeiden und Risiken zu
managen die auf jeden Fall vorhanden
sind und von dem Hintergrund ist
natürlich einerseits klar dass auch
eskalationsängste auch geschürt werden
und ähm auch
werden um gewisse ja politische Ziele
auch zu erreichen dass es auch glaube
das gehört dazu das gehört auch immer
bei bei abschreckungslücken dazu
aber ich würde auch so weit gehen eben
der Gipfel ist eigentlich ein Ergebnis
davon was was momentan möglich gewesen
ist zeigt auch für mich eben noch mal
dass die Vereinigten Staaten sich jetzt
auch nicht in aus ihrer Logik in
Konflikte eskalationsszenarien in Europa
hineinziehen wollen genau und der Faktor
eben auch immer den Fokus auf dem
indupazifik haben das ist definitiv auch
ein Punkt trotzdem es gab ja die
Erwartung vor Papst dass die Ukraine
meine Einladung bekommt eine stärkere
Beitrittsperspektive hat selensky auch
ganz klar gesagt gestern war er da auch
viel fordern da noch also was bedeutet
das jetzt also wie viel wie fährt
selenski jetzt nach Hause
also dass er sich heute relativ positiv
vor den Kameras gezeigt hat und in
Begleitung von Präsident beiden und
Scholz ist ja nicht wirklich
überraschend was sollte er auch sonst
tun also der gute Mann läuft jetzt seit
Monaten herum und er bittet und er
bettelt Waffenhilfe hat unheimlich viele
bilaterale Gespräche und hat sich
natürlich gewünscht er würde eine
Einladung bekommen ich möchte hier noch
mal den Punkt machen es ist ein totaler
Unterschied ob wir von einem Beitritt
reden oder von einer Einladung ich
erinnere mich dass keine Hysterie
ausgebrochen ist als beispielsweise die
Ukraine eine Einladung als Beitritt als
aspiranz zur Europäischen Union bekommen
hat und es gibt auch in der Europäischen
Union die wir alle wissen eine
beistandpflicht keiner ist ja
ausgebrochen und hat gesagt also
übermorgen bricht der dritte Weltkrieg
aus und ich glaube der Punkt den
selenski gemacht hat und der natürlich
nicht nur von ihm sondern auch von
vielen anderen osteuropäischen Staaten
und anderen Ukraine
Unterstützung gemacht worden ist dass
zumindest ein bisschen sozusagen ein
Stück weit sich von der Bukarest Sprache
2008 zu lösen und nicht nur dasselbe zu
bemühen mit ein bisschen kosmetischen
Veränderungen was wir vor 15 Jahren
beschlossen haben ich war auf diesem
Gipfel dabei ich in Bukarest ich kann
mich noch sehr gut an diese Debatten
erinnern und deswegen plädiere ich auch
sehr leidenschaftlich dafür die Ukraine
wirklich aus dieser
sicherheitspolitischen Grauzone endlich
zu befreien und wir haben sie seit
gestern immer noch in dieser schlammzone
aber mit einer Unterstützung für mehr
Waffen und all das und wenn ich mir noch
kurz alle fügen darf wir haben seit 20
Jahren in der NATO regelmäßig fast jedes
Jahr weitere militärische
Unterstützungsprogramme für die Ukraine
erlassen das was heute in der G7
Erklärung steht ist quasi eins zu eins
also was wir schon in den letzten zehn
weiter gekommen können
erlassen wie man es auch bei Finnland
und bei Schweden gemacht hat also
haben erfüllen muss wenn man mittig
werden
2008 das war nicht der Sündenfall wo wir
uns ich sage mal bei gewissen ehemaligen
bundeskanzlerinnen dann schon erkundigen
sollten warum sie zweimal also 2008 und
11 sich gegen den Beitritt ausgesprochen
hat und der französische möchte jetzt
hier keine Namen nennen aber ich glaube
es ist klar
wir können ja mal zurückschauen in die
Geschichte also es fängt ja eigentlich
es gibt eine lange Geschichte von von
Ukraine nato-kontakten angefangen mit
mit dem action plan 2002 dann den den
discussionen Plan 2005
also es ist ja nicht so dass das jetzt
von heute auf morgen gekommen wäre oder
aber ich denke man kann auch nicht in
dieser Ausschließlichkeit vorgehen und
und sagen jetzt okay wir wir müssen von
heute auf gleich das ganze was für ein
Unterschied
gemacht wenn man jetzt der Ukraine eine
klare Einladung ausgesprochen hätte was
hätten es was hätten sie das Gute oder
schlecht gefunden jetzt schlecht
gefunden man zeichnet vor und ich bin
auch nicht der Meinung dass wir uns in
einer Grauzone befinden die
Unterstützung für
die Ukraine ist massiv sie hat den
Deutschland Diskussionen ausgelöst ich
selber gehöre zu denen die lange
geschwankt haben stimme ich den
Waffenlieferungen zu stimme ich ihnen
nicht zu ich weiß Frau Papst ist da viel
schneller als ich aber aufgrund der
deutschen Geschichte halte ich es für
wichtig dass man diese Diskussion führt
man hat einen Krieg sagen sie dann es
ist richtig Waffen zu liefern und wann
es ist richtig dass die Ukraine im
Moment all diese luftabwehrwaffen hat
und durch sie halt eben viele
überlegen
wie weit geht es geht um Nothilfe wie
weit geht die Nothilfe wie weit muss
Nothilfe gehen wo beginnt gegebenenfalls
Teams in juristischer Sprache zu sagen
ein nothilfeextest die Nothilfe geht
sehr weit und ich glaube wir üben eine
gute Nothilfe aber wenn es darum geht
jetzt eine ganz konkrete
Beitrittsperspektive zu geben ich
brauche doch
um dieses Land beitreten zu lassen
brauche ich Frieden in diesem Land und
ich kann doch nicht sagen
wir machen es wie der Trafik Soldat
schräg bei Jaroslav haasek der gesagt
hat und wir treffen uns nach dem Krieg
um 4:30 Uhr im Gasthaus zurück zum Kelch
ich brauche und das Wort fällt mir
sowieso klar dass die Ukraine jetzt
nicht beitreten können solange sie im
Krieg sind ja es ist klar
damit das Wort Frieden fällt und ich
muss mich ich muss auch über den Frieden
reden wie komme ich zum Frieden wenn wir
die historische Perspektive nehmen
kann hat 17,95 zum ewigen Frieden
geschrieben
ist kein natürlicher Zustand der muss
geschliftet werden
auch schon gesehen
ich wehre mich dagegen wenn ich das Wort
Frieden Sorge dass sie damit Putin
kommen das muss ich mir nicht gefallen
lassen natürlich will ich Frieden
von dem was sie eingangs gesagt haben
dass hier
imperialistisch brutal agiert wird
nichts weg und trotzdem muss ich mir
überlegen wie komme ich zum Frieden und
wenn es darum geht zum Frieden zu kommen
und
es geht um Menschenleben auf beiden
Seiten und wenn ein russischer
Hubschrauber abgeschossen wird kommen
auch Menschen zum Tode die sich nicht
gewünscht haben und nein das ist relativ
wenig überhaupt nicht relativieren aber
ich habe und das ganz kurz zu erzählen
was mich da so anpackt im Westen nichts
Neues wir haben erlebt wie der Film
ausgezeichnet wird und ich habe gesehen
in diesem Film wie Daniel Brühl denn
Matthias Erzberger der zufrieden
unterschrieben hat in Waffenstillstand
auf wunderbare Weise spielt und wie er
sagt wir müssen verhindern dass
weiterhin
hundertetausende von Soldaten in diesen
letzten Tagen verrecken und das ist in
Ukraine Krieg so es verrecken Soldaten
das hat der Krieg so an sich aber damit
kommen sie nicht weiter und eine Lösung
auch nicht näher das sind genau die
Argumente die wir in 22 gehört haben
miteinander zu reden versuchen was immer
dabei herauskommt wie würden sie es
beurteilen die jetzt wenn es eine
Einladung gibt eine klare Perspektive
für die Ukraine die Frau Papst so
unterstützen würde würden Sie denn sagen
dass wäre dann damit wäre es einfacher
ein Frieden zu verhandeln oder wäre das
jetzt viel schwieriger gut die Frage ist
halt was die Perspektive bedeutet na wie
man dahin kommt was hier Voraussetzungen
Bedingungen dafür sind dass es diesen
Schritt kommt was der was der Plan ist
und auch in den fern der eben
eskalationsrisiken und Risiko mit
einbezieht ich glaube letztendlich die
Unterstützung der Ukraine durch den
Westen ist ja sehr sehr deutlich auch
durch die Vereinigten Staaten ist es ja
deutlich auch durch Deutschland
dass da die Abwehrfähigkeit auch der
Ukraine gestützt wird und auch die
Fähigkeit zu offensiven
kriegsförderungen das ist alles da und
auch richtig
es ist halt nur der der Punkt bei der
ganzen Forderungen auch in Ukraine
NATO-Beitritt
Sicherheitsgarantien und so weiter
was bedeuten die wie werden die
ausgestaltet und was ist die potenzielle
Aggressionen auch Russland sagen dass
sie das klar ist dass die Ukraine die
NATO gehört am Ende dieses Krieges nach
dem Krieg kann man darüber reden das
möchte
aber sie sagen erstmal soll erst nach
dem Krieg darüber reden
das gehört auch zu den Verhandlungen die
ich mir wünsche
definitiv in die in den Franz
atlantischen Raum das ist das ist völlig
klar die Frage ist halt nur wie kommen
wir dahin und wie kommen wir dahin
was denken Sie welches Signal jetzt in
Richtung Russland ausgeht von diesem
Gipfel also ist es ja ein ist es ein
starkes Zeichen der Abschreckung eine
NATO die da sich gerade an die Seite der
Ukraine setzt oder ist es eher ein
Zeichen der Schwäche dass man eben keine
klare Einladung ausspricht ist es sicher
nicht es ist eine strategische
Perspektive und die richtet sich
natürlich auch an Russland man gibt
Russland damit schon zu verstehen ihr
könnt den Krieg gerne weiterführen wenn
ihr wollt aber am historischen Ergebnis
dass ich einstellen wird werdet ihr
nichts ändern und ich denke man muss
sich endlich mal angewöhnen in dieser
Diskussion die Sache vom Ergebnis her zu
sehen auch das ja ein berühmtes Zitat
und das das Ergebnis dieses Krieges ist
das ukrainischer Sicht ein eindeutig
nämlich die Wiederherstellung der
ukrainischen Souveränität in die Grenzen
von 1991 Punkt und das Schließen genau
deswegen habe ich grundsätzlich ein
Problem mitbegriffen wie Verhandlungen
weil ich nicht davon ausgehen dass
dieses Regime das russische
überhaupt über so einem Ziel verhandeln
wird dann hieß hier ein Ende des Krieges
wäre eine Kapitulation Russland nein
nicht unbedingt ist sondern einfach ein
Abzug der russischen Truppen Kriege und
es ist wichtig dass man das versteht
werden nicht zwingend durch
Verhandlungen beendet auch nicht durch
friedensverhandlung kriegen werden zum
Beispiel auch durch einseitige
Erklärungen oder auch durch faktische
Handlungen beendet das heißt also
Russland könnte erklären einseitig wir
hören jetzt auf wir ziehen uns zurück
oder sie könnten auch gar nichts
erklären und sich zurückziehen aber ich
denke schon
bitte es gibt nicht viele Kriege
prominentes Beispiel haben wollen aber
die Frage war Regulation aber die Frage
war jetzt eigentlich eine andere worum
es worum es eigentlich geht ist ich sage
das noch mal ist die Aufrüstung der
Ukraine also sprich dass die Ukraine als
Staat in der Lage ist ihre Souveränität
glaubwürdig zu verteidigen und da ist
natürlich selber als aktiver Partner
genau teilnimmt und das ist ein
Alternativmodell wo man also sagen das
wäre dann so was beiden ja ich glaube
vorgestern hat das angedeutet das wäre
so eine Art Israel Modell also man hilft
der Ukraine quasi massiv bei der
selbstaufrüstung und sieht das als eine
Art Zwischenmodell und sagt dann okay
und und wenn sie dann westlich
aufgerüstet hat und ihre Prozesse und
ihre
institutionäre Form soweit sind dass man
das dann überführt in in einer NATO
Mitgliedschaft das wäre vielleicht so
ein Kompromiss Modell der Sicherheit
Berater des amerikanischen Präsidenten
hat gesagt die Ukraine jetzt
hereinzulassen hätte bedeutet dass die
NATO im Krieg mit Russland ist Frau
Papst wie sehen Sie das und der
grimmelsprecher hat gesagt die
Sicherheit Garantien der G7 für die
Ukraine Schaden der Sicherheit Russland
also wie stark oder wie klar wäre eine
Einladung was von Signal ist das
Richtung Russland ihrer Meinung nach
also ich glaube wir müssen hier mal ein
paar Dinge unterscheiden also
militärisch gesehen hat Russlands seit
16 Monaten die militärische Eskalation
sind Initiative es tut und treibt was es
in der Ukraine werden möchte und wir im
Westen kommentierendes wir sind empört
aber wenn ich beispielsweise an die
militärische Zerstörung des Verkaufs
denke ganz konkret außer Empörung oder
nüchternen Darstellung des Bundeskanzler
Scholz der sagt das ist eine neue
Dimension des Krieges erfolgt nichts
aber keine wirkliche sozusagen
strategische Reaktion auf diese
Eskalation seitens Russland aussehen
können Ihre Meinung nach also wir hätten
selbstverständlich also mit mehr als nur
ein paar Worten beispielsweise auch
konkrete hilfeleisten können im
Schwarzen Meer die Nato hat sich aus der
schwarzen meerregion zurückgezogen wir
haben Anrainerstaaten im Schwarzen Meer
unter anderem die Türkei Rumänien und
andere die von der ökologischen
Verseuchung und Kontaminierung unter
anderem auch betroffen sind es ist in
der NATO noch nicht mal über eine eine
Option debattiert worden gar nichts und
ich frage mich wirklich wann wir
sozusagen bereit sind im auf der
westlichen Seite hier
wegzukommen von dem Versuch zu
interpretieren wann haben Putin
irgendwelche roten Linien im Kopf hat
für mich ist es völlig klar hab Putin
hat eine eiserne Entschlossenheit das
zweitgrößte Land in der Mitte Europas
vor unseren Augen zu vernichten und er
wird es weiter tun weil er weiß dass er
keine wirkliche sozusagen Gegenwehr von
uns bekommt und wenn sie nicht gegen als
Unterstützung der Gegenwehr sehen seit
zum Monaten aus dem Krengel eine sehr
berechenbare und berechnende politische
Rhetorik Herr Putin und seinen seinen
Kompagnon die anderen Menschen aus
seiner ontourage wie er mit jedem alle
Nase lang mit der nuklearen Karte und
wir reagieren jedes Mal total
berechenbar die sind jedes Mal total
berechenbar aufgeregt und auch du meine
Güte ich behaupte einfach und ich denke
das mit durchaus plausiblen Gründen dass
wir uns von dieser dritte Welt
Armageddon Rhetorik wirklich mal
befreien müssen und sehr nüchtern sehen
dass wir hier in Europa wirklich an
einem strategischen Kreuzungspunkt
angekommen deshalb gibt's ja auch eine
strategische Neuausstellung der hat aber
sie wollte
ganz kurz dazu sagen wollen ich glaube
dass das mehr Russland haben dass eine
imperiale Logik verfolgt das steht denke
ich außer Frage auch eine gewisse zu
gewisse Mission verfolgt der Punkt ist
halt nur möchte man wirklich
ist man dazu bereit die Risiken
einzugehen um eine nuklearabe aber
nuklear macht strategisch zu überraschen
das ist die das ist die große Frage
russland hat versucht den Westen zu
überraschen die keine zu überraschen mit
dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine Tatsachen zu
schaffen das hat nicht so gut geklappt
und der Westen hat entgegengewirkt das
würde ich einfach mal betonen wollen und
letztendlich sollte auch wirklich
wirklich klar sein dass wenn man jetzt
keine Perspektive in der Einladung
ermöglicht hatte was dann die Konsequenz
sein können und dass die auch benannt
werden und wie gesagt die ja Risiken
Frau Papst sie müssen auf jeden Fall
stark involviert durch all die Lieferung
definitiv deswegen habe ich auch
betontin hat überhaupt gar keine Rolle
in der Koordinierung von Waffenlieferung
und sie hat deswegen keine Rolle das
wird alles da in Wiesbaden unter
amerikanischer Führung gemacht in der
sogenannten Rammstein Gruppe weil die
NATO ist nicht will und weil dort
Mitglieder sitzen wie beispielsweise
Deutschland und auch die USA
Arbeit beginnen das Krieges alles getan
haben um auch nur diese
koordinierungsrolle nur die Koordination
die NATO selber hat da wirklich eine
sehr sehr untergeordnete Rolle das muss
man einfach mal festhalten
der deutschen Bevölkerung dass die NATO
Kriegspartei sei oder durch
Waffenlieferungen dazu würde das ist sie
nicht und sie wird dadurch
nach Artikel 51 der un-karte und das ist
das Selbstverteidigungsrecht einer
souveränen Nation die völkerrechtlich
angegriffen wurde dass sie unterstützen
und das ist völlig legitim
völkerrechtlich und das muss man immer
wieder sagen weil die russische
Propaganda natürlich genau das Gegenteil
immer behauptet
genau diese russischen narrative auch
diese ständige dieses ständigen Exkurse
mit dem nuklear Säbel zu lassen es tut
mir leid die nukleare Abschreckung
funktioniert hervorragend und man hat
Russland mehrfach sehr deutlich klar
gemacht tut es lieber nicht weil
ansonsten
kommt ein Vergeltungsschlag das heißt
nicht zwingend das richtig aber ich kann
doch deswegen nicht so tun als wir die
atomare die nukleare Gefahr etwas der
sich vernachlässigen könnte es ist nicht
vernachlässigbar es unterscheidet die
gegenwärtige Situation von denen die
historische herangezogen werden
natürlich kann man Putin mit Hitler
vergleichen haben viele Historiker
gemacht aber es gibt halt eine
grundlegend andere Konstellationen bei
Münchner Abkommen 1939 das als apisment
beschrieben wird was es ja auch war gab
es keine
nukleare Gefahr und wir haben halt
erstens zweitens und drittens ein
ungeheueres atomares Potential und wenn
dieses Potenzial sie sagen so leicht
dann gibt's den Gegenschlag wenn es
diese Schläge und Gegenschläge gibt dann
gibt es Europa nicht mehr auf die genau
auf die russische atomerzählung nein
nein das lasse ich mir unterstellen es
ist so und da schauen Sie sich die
Debatten mit der Wissenschaftler auch
der
wissenschaftlerialtechnik nuklearer
Gegenschlag erstens sie können nicht das
Münchner Abkommen von 1938 mit der
heutigen Situation der nuklearen
Abschreckung vergleichen
wir haben völlig andere Voraussetzungen
wir haben völlig andere Gefahren und den
nukleare Gefahr ist einfach da nicht
besonders wichtig dass die NATO gerade
besonders stark sich zeigt aber das
Modell der Abschreckung hat ja im Kalten
Krieg auch funktioniert sie zeigt sich
doch die Mitgliedstaaten zeigen sich
durchaus stark und Deutschland ist ja
ein Beispiel hätten sie sich von einem
Jahr für eineinhalb Jahren vorstellen
können und dass sich Deutschland in der
Weise wie es jetzt sich zeigt engagiert
also wissen sie das wirklich beschämende
an der deutschen Politik ist dass sie
immer zu wenig und zu spät agiert ich
habe das mal Führung von hinten genannt
in einem anderen Interview das heißt man
versteckt sich so ein bisschen
internationen die zunächst mal voran
gehen wie zum Beispiel die britische
oder die polnische und erst wenn man es
dann gar nicht mehr verhindern kann dass
man auch ein bisschen mit ins Boot muss
ich verstehe ich verstehe die
Argumentation ich verstehe sie ja weil
die deutsche Geschichte ist eine
besondere Geschichte und wenn hier die
Debatten mit besonderer in grundgeführt
werden hat es einen Grund und ich werde
mich dagegen dass man über
mehr und noch mehr so redet als befinden
wir uns in einer militärischen Olympiade
wir befinden in einem Krieger
immer das gleiche haben sie das Putin
auch schon gesagt also verstehen sie
wenn der Mann nicht nicht
fortlaufend weiter den Krieg führen
würde dann müssten sie hier nicht diese
sogenannten eskalationsdebatten führen
und das stört mich ehrlich gesagt dass
die das die Diskussion immer so ein
bisschen umgedreht wird nach dem Motto
die westlichen kriegst treiben
dass ich jetzt den Putin das Wort Rede
das ist wirklich ein bodenloser Unsinn
und wenn hier eine wenn Sie eine Runde
gäbe bei der ich dann Putin sagen könnte
was ich ihm sagen will würde ich
natürlich sagen ich ist doch völlig
klargestellt sind dass das wer hier der
aggresso sind das ist glaube ich das
müssen wir hier nicht klarstellen
liefert Deutschland ja sehr viele Waffen
und ist man kann ja Deutschland nicht
unterstellen dass es sich nicht
beteiligt trotzdem jetzt auch wieder in
Litauen war der Kanzler zurückhaltend
gemeinsam mit den USA wie bewerten sie
denn da die deutsche Rolle
achtsames Vorgehen nennen ne dass da ähm
seit dem Kriegsbeginn auch auch läuft
und da ist es eine reinwachsen eine
Rolle klar ist auch die Frage hätte man
vielleicht vor ein paar Jahren bisschen
anders gehandelt hatte man eine gewisse
Dinge abchecken verhindern können das
ist das ist auch klar jetzt ist
Deutschland der bei der militärischen
Hilfe auch für die Ukraine vorne dabei
mit den mit den USA und hat glaube ich
auch halt die Funktion auch mit das
Bündnis zusammenzuhalten ne und so eine
Situation beizutragen also kurz um ich
sehe Deutschland auch in der in einer
kleinen Gegner Stellung gegenüber
Russland aber nicht als Kriegspartei und
finde die das Handy gemacht werden
im Vergleich zu anderen NATO-Ländern
fanden sie richtig ich fand die
deutschen Position und und Logik auf
jeden Fall vertretbar und das deutsche
war eigentlich alleine die USA war ja
auch dabei und das ist auch völlig klar
dass das Baltikum hat andere solcher
Erfahrung mit mit der odssr das ist das
ist auch klar dass man sich dann mehr
Abschreckung auch auch wünscht und
Unterstützung wünscht das ist aber das
sind halt verschiedene Interessen im
Bündnis von verschiedenen Staaten die
NATO ist eine kompromissmaschine und das
kommt bei raus und das war immer
realistisch drin und dann müssen wir
arbeiten arbeiten
ist ich weiß nicht wie ihre ist meiner
ist ganz offensichtlich anders ich bin
ich würde mir in der Tat weniger
zunächst einmal Selbstgefälligkeit
wünschen ich finde es ziemlich
unerträglich wenn ein Bundeskanzler nach
Vilnius fährt und sagt oh die
Partnerschaft oder vielmehr der
irgendwann am Tag X kommende Beitritt
der Ukraine ist auf einem guten Wege und
wir haben es 500 Tagen ein
Vernichtungskrieg in der Ukraine der
ungeheure Opfer fördert und an dem Tag
wo die Menschen sich in Vilnius treffen
Dollern die Russen weiter ihre Raketen
auch für Sonn und woanders also das
finde ich also komplett empathielos muss
ich sagen und der zweite Punkt den ich
machen möchte jeder Versuch eine
irgendwie geartete strategische Antwort
keine parteitaktische keine die auf
deutsche also geschichtliche Interessen
avisiert ist zu entwickeln müsste doch
zumindestens den Hauch einer kritischen
Selbstreflexion beinhalten den erkenne
ich in der deutschen Debatte überhaupt
gar nicht und wenn irgendjemand also bis
auf sehr wenige Ausnahmen die gesagt
haben oh wir haben also in den letzten
ein paar zwei Jahrzehnten also wirklich
gravierende Fehler im Umgang mit
Russland gemacht und wir haben nach 2014
weiter auch das russische Militär mit
Waffen beliefert und wir haben noch 20
14 auch weiter obwohl Russland so ganz
offensichtlich schon ein Aggressor war
auch weiter Herr Nordstrand 2 gepampert
also das wird alles vom Tisch gewischt
und dann sitze ich da jemand oder stellt
sich jemand hin und sagt aber wir machen
alles richtig und habt Vertrauen das
muss ich sagen ist eine Botschaft die
ich wirklich kaum ertragen kann und ich
weiß dass sie viele Menschen in der
Ukraine auch nicht ertragen aber der
Kanzler muss ja nun auch ganz stark in
Richtung seiner deutschen Bevölkerung
seine Botschaft richten jeder hat seinen
eigenen Anspruch meiner an politische
Führung und an strategische Weizen ist
ganz offensichtlich ein etwas anderes
mehr die Mehrheit der deutschen
Bevölkerung steht ja hinter den
Waffenlieferung aber wenn sie jetzt
ansprechen die die Erfahrung also womit
ist sich klar Russland handelt und sie
schauen das Baltikum an oder Polen da
bekommen Sie natürlich andere Töne jetzt
sagen Sie okay aber deutsche Politik
sondern deutsche Geschichte Sonderfall
ja gut aber ein Teil Deutschlands hat
eine sehr sehr intensive Erfahrung
gemacht mit zunächst sowjetischer
Besatzung und danach einem sowjetischen
Marionetten
Gruppe der sowjetischen Streitkräfte in
Deutschland muss ich nicht erläutern
400.000 Soldaten 5000 Panzer bereit
jederzeit in den Westen einzufallen und
Westdeutschland als Staat zu beseitigen
warum hören wir aus Deutschland solche
Töne nicht und ich glaube dass das hat
viel viel komplexere Ursachen und gut es
muss jetzt nicht alles wirklich so ein
schwarz-weiß denken sein wie in Polen
oder wie im Baltikum das sehe ich auch
ja aber ich denke schon dass nach diesem
Krieg die deutsche Politik sich viele
viele Fragen stellen also die die ähm
das Versprechen von Boris pistorisch vom
Verteidigungsministerium Minister jetzt
4000 Soldaten nach Litauen dauerhaft zu
schicken mit Familien all das erkrankte
wie sehen Sie das denn ist das nicht ein
Zeichen dass ich in Deutschland eben
ganz klar diese zeitenwände wirklich
eben sozusagen auf dieser Weise auch
manifestiert und ist es richtig so die
übrigen
Wände hätte man sich auch vor Jahren
wirklich nicht vorstellen können und
finden Sie das richtig oder finden Sie
da auch das ist ein Gefühl hätten sie da
auch die
trocken ist dass das eskalierend wirkt
ich halte dieses für richtig es muss
eingebettet sein eine Strategie ich sehe
die NATO und die deutsche
Militärpolitik nichts aus strategielos
wie das Frau Papst zieht ich glaube das
ist schon dann voranschreiten und es ist
ein vorsichtiges voranschreiten und ich
bin dankbar für dieses Zeit für Vorsicht
gerade ich glaube man muss vorsichtig
sein weil die Gefahren so groß sind und
ich hätte mir nicht gedacht dass ich
eines Tages in die Lage komme denn
Bundeskanzler Scholz zu verteidigen aber
ich bin im für diese Vorsicht
dankbar und
ich würde keinen Kanzler da sitzen haben
wollen der
hurra schreit
ich glaube was wir in Deutschland haben
und was zum Thema auch Selbstreflexion
zu sagen ist es ist glaube ich klar dass
Deutschland vor Kriegsbeginn oftmals als
eine Art von ja man könnte sagen Reserve
Christus aufgetreten ist sehr belehrend
definitiv
vielleicht auch ein bisschen nicht
deutlich genug gemacht hat dass man halt
eine europäische Großmacht ist sich ein
bisschen in deine Verantwortung des Kurs
auch versteckt hat würde ich jetzt nicht
sagen könnte man
weiß gutes Beispiel auf jeden Fall
konnte man das gebrauchen ne der Punkt
ist aber der dass man eben jetzt nicht
von von so einem Punkt halt in ein
anderes Extrem switchen sollten als wenn
ich zum 01 Logik gekommen nicht so so
schwarz-weiß kommen so unsere
Mittelposition kommen die zum Beispiel
sich auch daran ähm ja ausdrückt in
dieser europäischen Initiative wo das
macht in der Mittelposition ist nee das
wir nicht dazu neigen sollten dass wir
zwischen einer Null und Eins Position
uns bewegen von einerseits davor
vielleicht auch eine oder mit Sicherheit
auch eine Unterschätzung auch der
Bedrohung durch Russland für das
europäische Sicherheit und jetzt halt zu
einer neuen Logik kommen halt die dann
sagt na gut dann testen wir mal aus wie
die wo die russischen roten Linien sind
und hoffen dass die Russen zuerst
blinzeln weil das ist ja auch natürlich
politische Logiken und nicht zwingend
militärische und und für mich wäre
eigentlich das eher der Punkt also ich
habe das ja vorhin gesagt juli little to
late so wenn sie jetzt gerade Pistole
ist erwähnen oder
ein ganz klares es gibt von Deutschland
keine Flugzeuge so sprich wie selbst ist
wird ja eine F16 Koalition der Willigen
geben die es 16 liefert wird an die
Ukraine die Frage ist nur noch wie viele
und wann aber Deutschland wird sich
daran nicht beteiligen wir hatten genau
die gleiche Diskussion bei der
Artillerie ja wir erinnern uns im Mai
222 hach Artillerie ist das nicht sehr
gefährlich und können die Ukraine das
überhaupt bedienen wir hatten genau die
gleiche Diskussion zu Beginn des Kriege
von 5000 Helme und Feldspital aber dann
ist auch gut weil alles andere
geliefert ja zum Glück aber erst nach
nach immer der gleichen innenpolitischen
Schleife nach dem Motto erzeugen wir
damit nicht den Dritten Weltkrieg ist
das nicht zu aggressiv dürfen wir das
überhaupt und so weiter dann wenn zwei
andere Staaten schon geliefert haben
dann schließt man sich so ein bisschen
zögerlich an
oder wie auch immer in England gibt es
mittlerweile ein eigenes Verb dafür
scholzing also wo man sagt wenn es halt
gar nicht mehr anders geht dann
schließen wir uns dem ganzen so ein
bisschen an gut das mag vielleicht zu
tun haben mit der deutschen politischen
Kultur des mag sein aber das die
militärischen Realitäten die sind andere
und die sind ganz einfach sie zwingen im
Moment die Ukraine einen Krieg zu führen
wie keine moderne Nation sie jemals
führen würde dann krieg ohne Luft
Überlegenheit ja ein Krieg mit mit
artilleristischen Mitteln wo sie betteln
müssen um um jede Kanone
wirklich politische wegklammern sie
sollen da ist die militärische Logik
gekommen und nach militärischen
Gesichtspunkten muss ich so handeln sie
können doch nicht verlangen die Politik
auszublenden die Politik in der Art und
Weise wie sie agiert wie sie wirkt wie
sie argumentiert muss doch die Politik
die ich militärisch
dann entfalte gerechtfertigen aber
wissen Sie wenn Sie jetzt sagen sie
wollen politisch so handeln dass sie am
Ende Frieden bekommen dann würde ich
sagen ist der einfachste Weg die Ukraine
so zu unterstützen dass sie für sich
selber Frieden schaffen kann indem sie
die russische Aggression neutralisiert
und die russischen Truppen hinauswirft
und das würde bedeuten entschlossener zu
handeln und nicht abwägen
also welche Maßnahmen werden als ihr das
nicht erforderlich um dahin zu kommen
wir können zunächst mal in die
Vergangenheit zurückblicken und sagen
ein Großteil der Kriegsopfer und der vor
allem auch der Zivilisten die bis jetzt
gestorben sind in diesem Krieg wären
vielleicht nicht gestorben wenn man
früher entschlossener gehandelt hätte
hätte
zum Beispiel ja aber was die Ukraine
jetzt am trinken braucht ist Luft
Überlegenheit das hat sie zum Beispiel
jetzt bei dagegen Offensive nicht sie
muss eine Gegend Offensive führen also
wenn wir bei Autos sind die NATO würde
sowas niemals machen denken oder das
erste was sie machen massive Luft
Überlegenheit und dann drücken sie vor
am Boden die Ukraine muss das im Moment
andersrum machen weil der Westen zu
zögerlich ist und sie mit
luftkampfmitteln zu unterstützen und so
sollte man die Sachen mal sehen
ich kann diesen Punkt wirklich nur
komplett unterstützen und möchte daran
erinnern dass wir auf der ukrainischen
Seite hochkompetente Führungsstäbe haben
wir haben mit dem Generalstabschef
saluschnee ich glaube den kompetentesten
und erfahrenen militärischen Führer hier
überhaupt in Europa das muss man
wirklich sagen kriegserfahren jemand der
seit 20 14 sich sozusagen auf einen
kriegerisches Szenario ähm nicht nur
theoretisch politisch irgendwo im Raum
sondern ganz konkret mit seinen Soldaten
an der Frontlinie einlässt und der
schickt in regelmäßigen Abständen seine
requirements also seine sozusagen Liste
mit den militärischen Notwendigkeiten
die ja an entlang sozusagen anhand des
ähm der der militärischen Dynamik
entwickelt so
und dann kommt er mit seiner Liste und
dann gibt es das was ich ich muss leider
sagen was ich aus der Zeit in der ich in
der NATO war und das erlebt habe was wir
beispielsweise zugunsten Afghanistans
gemacht haben das ist für mich Mama
wirklich ein Deja Vu es gibt eine
platching-konferenz nach der anderen es
wird geplätscht ohne Ende
heißt man sozusagen die Nationen
sagen ich mache das ich mache das ich
schicke das ich schicke das und dann
wird dann Preisschild dran gehängt
selbstverständlich wird das immer medial
sehr gut aufbereitet so wie wir das
gestern und vorgestern auch in Senius
bekommen haben und was kommt dann an was
hat denn der lustige gesagt was eben
alles fehlt ähm was eben halt von dem
plattes vor es wird versprochen aber es
wird da nicht geliefert ich will sagen
gar nichts geliefert wird aber es dauert
zu ergänzen es wird nicht in Gänze
geliefert es wird immer zu spät
geliefert also zeitverzögert wenn ich
jetzt an die F16 denke wird davon
geredet dass das Training in einem
halben Jahr beginnen kann in einem
halben Jahr wissen Sie wie viele
ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten bis
dato wirklich
gestorben sein werden wie viel also das
ist doch also was ist das für eine
Planung es wird gestorben und
wenn ich sie reden höre was militärisch
notwendig ist dann denke ich mir
vielleicht wäre ein Teil dieser
Forderungen
wichtiger und besser als diese streubom
einzusetzen mit denen sich die
Amerikaner jetzt irgendwo hinauswänden
ich weiß nicht Russen dass seit 22
Jahren auch und gerade gegen Zivilisten
am 8 April 22 diese Waffe ist
verabscheuern wird
die Konvention die gerade 15 Jahre alt
ist die unser Bundespräsident als
Außenminister noch unterschrieben hat
aber ich der ist ungut ich finde es
ungut auch in bester Absicht grausamste
Waffen einzusetzen da schreiten wir da
wirkt sich da wirft das Grenzweg zurück
reden sie wissen schon dass weder
Russland noch die Ukraine noch die USA
die Konvention über natürlich
weiß ich das trotzdem sind die Waffen
gehören zu den grausamsten Waffen die es
gibt und ich finde es wirklich falsch
und wir führen diesen Krieg und wir sind
bei diesem Wetter
und dann können wir nicht Waffen
einsetzen die wirklich
ja unmoralisch müssen sie eigentlich der
größte F16 Befürworter überhaupt sein
wenn sie wenn ich habe gerade gesagt
bevor ich
Streubomben liefere in einer Dimension
die ungeheuerlich ist muss ich an andere
waffenkonzepte denken da könnte man
darüber reden gucken
natürlich ja trotzdem den Einsatz davon
auch das Völkerrecht Geld ne
Unterscheidung
zwischen Kommandanten Zivilisten auch
was ist legitimes Ziel was nicht es ist
auch klar dass wesentliche Militärmächte
bei der Konvention nicht dabei sind das
ist auch daher kommt dass eben die
Unterstützung der Ukraine durch
Artillerie Munition die Produktion von
Munition das ist schwer angelaufen ist
das ist alles die Folge davon sollte man
natürlich mitdenken ich glaube wenn wir
jetzt nach vorne gucken was was ist
notwendig oder was kann kommen es ist
klar eine Bestätigung der Unterstützung
für die Ukraine auch mal darüber
nachdenken wie kann das nach dem nach
dem Krieg weitergehen wir haben auch
nächstes Jahr in NATO Summit ein Gipfel
in Washington DC das auch mal ganz ganz
wesentlich auch Jubiläum der Allianz
nächstes Jahr auch eine Wahl in den USA
das ist ja auch noch mal die Frage
wie sehr muss man dieses Zeitfenster
jetzt nutzen weil man nicht weiß ob im
November 24 vielleicht Donald Trump der
nächste Präsident ist wie wichtig ist es
dann jetzt halt eben dann doch noch mal
stärker die unter die Ukraine zu
unterstützen
ich halte alles für wichtig und für
notwendig und
für
verdringlich was möglichst schnell
diesen Krieg beendet und welche Rolle
kann die NATO dabei spielen oder jetzt
nach diesem Gipfel was würden Sie denn
sagen Frau Babs gibt es auch was
positives wo sie sagen dieser Gipfel hat
gezeigt dass die NATO ja sich noch mal
neuer aufstellen anders aufstellt um
sich auch verteidigungsbereit in dieser
in diesem großen hat zweifelsohne auch
in Vilnius mit einem ganz besonderen
Paket ihre eigenen Zäune weiter
hochgezogen das ist das was ich
sozusagen als interne Hausaufgabe
bezeichne ich will das hier nicht
verniedlichen aber das ist aus meiner
Sicht etwas das Ding zu sehen von dem
was ich wirklich als die wirklich größte
strategische Herausforderung für Europa
betrachtete und das ist die Frage wie
weit wir uns ähm wirklich nicht nur auf
die Seite oder sozusagen einen Zaun ist
reinstellen sondern wirklich auf die
Seite der Ukraine ich denke mal dass
hier jetzt
ein Plan B einplanen C überlegen wird es
ist ganz offenkundig dass von der NATO
jetzt erstmal weiter nichts kommt also
außer das was sozusagen an
Waffenlieferung es gab schon noch eine
Zusage für mehr Waffen jetzt von den
geblieben
das ist aber kein strategischer
Paradigmenwechsel von dem ich hier die
ganze Zeit Rede und ihn einfordere das
ist sozusagen ein netteres sozusagen
anderes Wort für weiter so und deswegen
glaube ich dass die Ukraine sich
außerhalb der NATO im Rahmen ihrer
Unterstützergruppe
weiter Unterstützung suchen wird wir
werden sehen dass über die
Sicherheitsleistung
Unterstützungsleistung die auch Energie
7 jetzt versprochen worden sind ja immer
noch die Frage komplett offen ist wer
denn am Ende des Tages über Security
garanties also über richtige Garantien
bereit ist zu reden und dass sie
aussehen das wird in einigen
Hauptstädten bereits seit ein paar
Monaten sehr diskret aber ich denke sehr
zielorientiert diskutiert und ich denke
mal die Ukraine wäre gut beraten sich
eben halt sozusagen auf einen Plan C
oder B einzulassen aber nicht darauf zu
hoffen wie auf Godot einen schönen Tages
auch in Washington oder am Tag X mit
einem amerikanischen Präsidenten beiden
oder einem anderen diesen Bündnis
beizutreten denn wir reden von einem Tag
X in einer wirklich großen Ferne das ist
die Frage wie groß die Ferne ist ich
habe sie mal so verstanden dass sie
denken dass der Krieg nicht mehr so
lange dauert
der Krieg strategisch entschieden sein
wird in diesem Herbst das heißt aber
nicht dass die Kampfhandlungen dann
aufhören über die militärischen Gründe
habe ich mich in etlichen Interviews
geäußert aber wenn wir noch mal auf das
Thema Sicherheitsgarantien zurückkommen
das ist für die Ukraine nämlich eine
ganz zentrale Frage weil die hat nämlich
mit dem Budapester memorand und von 94
nicht gerade gute Erfahrungen gemacht
was das Thema Sicherheit Garantien
angeht also nach Auto wenn ich sie dann
wirklich brauche dann ist natürlich
und dann ist nämlich nichts zweiter
Weltkrieg wo England und Frankreich dann
sagen okay aber unsere
Sicherheitsgarantien gegenüber Polen die
die sind jetzt wirklich was wert wir
erklären dem Deutschen Reich den Krieg
sondern diesmal ist die Lage wir haben
das Budapester Russland marschiert 21
sondern 14 was passiert nicht und dann
kommt die volle Invasion 22 was passiert
nicht also sie können sich vorstellen
das Thema Sicherheitsgarantien oder
dieses Wort ist in der Ukraine nicht
jetzt gerade sehr sehr groß angesehen
und ich denke das ist jetzt für die
nächste Zukunft die spannende Frage wie
konkret will man das ausgestalten also
welche glaubwürdigen zusagen kann
britische Verteidigungsminister hat
heute gesagt man hätte man würde auch
gerne mal ein Danke hören von der
Ukraine das ist richtig
und ja ich glaube nicht dasselinski
undankbar ist heute hat er sich ja
schon in die Richtung eingelassen und
ja es gehört zum großen Tod des in
diesem in diesem Szenario
das ist menschlich verständlich was der
Brief sagt okay vielen dank für die
Diskussion Herr Brandler Feller Frau
Papst und Herr Kolb vielen dank ihnen
fürs Interesse bei uns geht's weiter mit
Phoenix der Tag von meiner Kollegin
Julia Grimm bis dann
[Musik]
sie träumen von Freiheit Frieden
Selbstbestimmung 44 Jahre nach der
Islamischen Revolution wollen sich die
Frauen im Iran nicht mehr beherrschen
lassen sie kämpfen gegen das harte
Regime ihres Landes wir wollen unsere
Rechte Menschenrechte wieder zurück
haben
woher kommt der Mut iranischer Frauen
und kann ihre Revolte gelingen Auftakt
für unser dokthema Frau Leben Freiheit
morgen
22:15 Uhr bei Phoenix
Phoenix der Tag
einen schönen guten Abend liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer